я буду це казати на кожному засіданні
парламенту крім одного крім того дня
коли в весь наш порядок денний буде про
військових я звертаюсь до вас чому в нас
сьогодні знову як вчора був порядок
денний і в ньому не було жодного питання
військових сьогодні це перше питання
Подивіться які пристрасті були обирають
голову комітету всі йогожили всі тут
така
боротьба Друзі А де питання про
військових де питання
демобілізації заміни військових тих хто
відслужив 18 місяців де питання
демобілізації строковиків де це питання
яким вже пообіцяли це з усіх трибун
включно зі ставки Верховного
головнокомандувача де законопроект про
ротацію супер потрібний супер необхідний
боє підрозділи які не змінюються там вже
20 місяців а є які два роки ті які ще до
повномаштабного вторння на Донбасі
стояли на гарячих дільницях фронту і
вони і зараз сьогодні там стоять і це
вже відбувається два роки де всі ці
закони Я закликаю негайно негайно це все
розглянути Я закликаю Я закликаю
шановного пана голову Верховної Ради
погоджувальну Раду будь ласка сформуйте
порядок денний наступних засідань так
щоби обов'язково під в день засідання в
нас бу було щонайменше декілька питань
про військових тому що там безліч питань
я звертаюсь до голови Верховної Ради
звернутися до Президента щодо підписання
закону про списання військового майна
яке ми проголосували тут на початку
жовтня третій місяці де президент його
не підписав це дуже важливий закон який
полегшує життя військовим і зменшує
бюрократію війську Я закликаю поставити
на голосування і дати доручення комітету
з нацбезпеки нарешті Шановний пане
завітневич голова комітету з питань
національної безпеки і оборони будь
ласка нарешті 8 місяців вас лежить в
комітеті законопроект про демобілізацію
військових після 18 місяців служби про
ротацію вже лежить давно законопроект
про звільнення інвалідів першої другої
групи законопроект дати право
звільнитися тим хто пройшов полон це все
є ці всі законопроекти в Раді давайте
розглядати от сьогодні це перше питання
яке стосується військових це трагічне
питання але на жаль да це теж є і ми
маємо Ого вирішити Ну але ж це перше
сьогодні питання І останнє в порядку
денному і воно стосується невеликої
категорії ще раз важливий закон але
невеликої категорії А коли ми будемо
розглядати поруч з ним поряд з ним
закони які стосуються сотень тисяч людей
Ну ми же ну реально вони пішли захищати
всіх нас Ну так давайте ми тут Захистимо
їх їхні права сьогодні сама обмежена в
своїх правах категорія в державі сама
ображена категорія військова службовці
Це божевілля люди зі зброєю в руках про
яких ми кожен день говоримо а в них
найменше прав найменше прав в нашій
державі в них найменше в них прав менше
ніж в ув'язнених у в'язниці ну Уявіть
собі ті хоча б знають свій термін коли
вони знаходяться тому Я закликаю будь
ласка порядок денний про військових
включіть ці питання Шановний пане голово
доручіть будь ласка комітету з
нацбезпеки і оборони розглянути
законопроекти які стосуються розглянути
в них більше 100 законопроектів лежить
вони з них розглянули 14 ну це
неправильно Так не можна працювати чи
треба їхати хай в часі в яв проїдуть
проведуть засідання Все стане на свої
місця ЗСУ Слава збройним силам України